[Music]
I'm not going to give you a question you
think you are fake news
as long as you're Meryl I've there will
be newspapers that will be magazines I
wanted to start by getting your sense of
the scale of turmoil we're in right now
we've seen in the last few months the
election of Donald Trump Britain is on
its way out of the European Union is
this a wake-up call to the status quo or
is it the beginning of a new era in
global politics I think something which
really will seem coming for a while I
mean how many conferences have you been
at with titles like the need for
inclusive capitalism or just capitalism
or the growing dangers of growing income
inequalities you are you perhaps the
quintessential insider outsider you were
born in Greece you're outside the US
you've moved from one side of the
political spectrum to the other stealing
of my accent
you still have your accent but now you
know I think you're on the consummate
insider um do you think you know both
sides of this do you think that the u.s.
in particular but the Western world
broadly is going to be able to come up
with the kind of agenda that's needed
well I'm a congenital optimist both
because I'm Greek and as an as an
immigrant of the United States I think
we will but it all depends on on how
wise our leaders are going to be and if
you think of it we're drowning in data
and starved for wisdom and if you look
at their leaders of the past there was a
lot more time for reflection I mean one
of my favorite stories is FDR you know
being pressured by Churchill II to enter
the war at a time when the American
public was dead against it and what did
he do he did something which would be
unheard of today he took ten days off on
a naval ship to think and reflect
can you imagine imagine how can imagine
anyone announcing I'm taking ten days
off to reflect but he came back with
what was regarded here as his political
masterpiece the land lease program that
allowed him to sell entering the war to
the American public which basically
changed the course of history
I think right now there is this
incredible gap between what we know we
need to do and what we are doing and
what we have been doing for years and
this gap can only be bridged by wise
leaders
[Music]
what do you think has been the role of
the media in this growth of populism has
the media fuelled it the media had
definitely a role in the traffic turi I
think the beginning of the of the
election cycle and he was given an
amount of publicity and very uncritical
publicity that was not justified by
anything except the ratings is there a
danger that in certain it's it's already
over for the mainstream media in the
sense that it's gonna be very hard for
them to hold Donald Trump to account in
a way that matters compared to perhaps
between 20-30 years ago and right now I
think mainstream media have an even
greater responsibility now to publish
news that they have not verified
especially during the next four years
when they're going to be plenty of
legitimate reasons for the media to
criticize Trump to criticize him for
things that are not rihanna's going to
be very diligent amaizing let's talk
about what happens going forward Donald
Trump has a direct connection to 117
million people on Twitter and many more
through Facebook has he in some sense
disintermediated the mainstream media
yes in some sense he has but it's not
always for the good in terms of his own
interests either I think somebody should
take away his phone in the middle of the
night because thus far he has been
saying that he was going to tweet less
but actually he finds this a direct
route to speak to people but I think
it's also a direct way to vent I mean he
takes the bait one of the other
phenomena that we're seeing a lot of is
this quote disdain for experts in some
sense the disdain for experts is as as
important and or as part of the public
discussion now as the disdain for for
the media people gravitate to the
opinions they like rather than wanting
to be challenged or too many people are
so do you think that we can really get
back to a world where there is one
single view that was the sort of
mainstream view well I think we have to
absolutely get back to the
is such a thing as truth but the
mainstream media have a responsibility
for where we are now because if you
think of it and the assumption that
every story had two sides and that
whether it was climate change or was
Obama born or not born in the United
States the mainstream media tended to
have that sort of false equivalence has
been one of the problems with the
assumption that somehow there is no
truth Arianna Huffington thank you very
much thank you